plusieurs centaines de sans-papiers les
gilets noirs nous at-on dit occuper le
panthéon ce lieu de mémoire où reposent
simone veil jean moulin andré malraux
victor hugo aussi monsieur le premier
ministre je vous demande combien de
procédures de raccompagnement aux
frontières ont été engagées après la
profanation profanations indignes
dimanche ça continue à paris à lyon à
marseille et dans bien d'autres villes
des voitures à nouveau brûlé des
policiers à nouveau agressée à saint
denis
c'est un commissariat qui était attaqué
au mortier
face à cette situation ne nous dit pas
monsieur le premier ministre que les
policiers et ont été remarquables nous
le savons nous les soutenons nous le
rendons régulièrement un hommage appuyé
monsieur le premier ministre
tous ces événements pouvaient être
anticipée et pourtant rien n'a été fait
l'autorité de l'état a été bafoué votre
ministre de l'intérieur totalement
dépassé et vous même monsieur le premier
ministre avait été particulièrement muet
face à la gravité de cette situation
ma question est donc simple jusque quand
allez-vous vous complaire dans cette
incapacité à rétablir l'ordre
républicain
il est choquant est révélateur de voir
cette nuée de drapeaux algériens brandis
par des français issus de l'immigration
dont les parents ont délibérément fait
le choix de la france comme nouvelle
patrie il est choquant de voir ce type
de manifestations violentes
d'autant plus le jour même de notre fête
nationale violence que l'état donne
l'impression d'accepter comme une
fatalité et qu'il ne gère qu'au coup par
coup
les français en ont assez il est temps
de ramener la paix sociale dans notre
pays
en recréant une unité de valeurs
républicaines sont favorisées comme tel
est le cas aujourd'hui les
communautarismes de toutes sortes
ces violences est révélatrice d'un
problème plus profond
plus grave il est temps de repenser
notre politique d'intégration
il est temps comme le disait le
prédisant le président retailleau ou de
s'attaquer aux racines du mal à 100 ce
travail sans fermeté sans une reconquête
de l'école et des quartiers difficiles
sans une réponse immédiate rien ne
pourra être résolue il ya quelques
semaines la cour des comptes pointait du
doigt le budget de l'état avec ses
dépenses qui augmentent son déficit qui
augmentent malgré des recettes en
augmentation aussi donc on s'aperçoit
que vous avez du mal à maîtriser les
dépenses publiques et qu'il vous reste
peut être des solutions vous avez déjà
adopté cette demande et aux autres de le
faire elle 3 159 milliards d'euros c'est
le montant de la dette publique au
premier trimestre en france
ce n'est plus une petite montagne de
dettes c'est un everest de dettes pour
bien se rendre compte ce que ce chiffre
vertigineux représente il faut le
ramener aux 67 millions d'habitants cela
représente par habitant 35000 210 euros
de dettes ainsi une épée de damoclès
plane au dessus de la tête de chaque
français et face à cet everest de dette
quel choix faites-vous d'augmenter
encore les dépenses publiques plus 4,6
milliards d'euros pour un budget de 260
7,5 milliards d'euros alors qu'il existe
des économies à faire
sur le train de vie de l'état le
périmètre de la fonction publique
réforme de la émeut en réévaluant
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
j'en reviens donc à ma question pourquoi
abandonnez vous la promesse électorale
du candidat emmanuel macron de plus de
sérieux budgétaire et je cite de ne pas
léguer une dette insoutenable à nos
enfants passent l'épreuve du brevet n'a
pas échappé non plus aux situations tout
à fait ubuesque ainsi du fait de la
canicule
toutes les épreuves du brevet ont été
déplacées au 1er et 2 juillet certains
élèves était dans l'incapacité de se
présenter à l'examen et c'était donc
inscrit au rattrapage de septembre
quelle n'a pas été leur surprise pour
certains d'entre eux d'apprendre qu'ils
étaient reçus sans avoir passé les
preuves mettant tout mais tout en
restant inscrits pour passer l'épreuve
en septembre ma question est donc simple
car beaucoup d'élèves et de famille cela
pose
monsieur le ministre après avoir été
officiellement reçus au brevet des
collèges ses élèves de devront ils oui
ou non
repasser l'épreuve en septembre et par
ailleurs qu'allez vous faire pour que de
telles situations ubuesques ne se
reproduise plus à l'avenir parce que
vous avez tout de même en charge le
service public de l'éducation nationale
l'été at il la volonté monsieur le
ministre de faire de l'aménagement du
territoire une priorité malgré un
discours qui se veut rassurant sans que
l'état est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui choisi de privilégier les
recettes en 2025 deux tiers de la
population serait couverte donc un tiers
ne le serais porte la fracture numérique
vont encore se creuser
il
[Musique]